die frau bisher dorf dass ich heute das
display team darf das training relativ
lange dreivierteljahr kann so ein
training in einigen prüfungen sehr viel
und simulatoren und hat da musst du erst
mal vor publikum wir sind hier noch der
freue mich sehr darauf
begonnen hat so ich habe mal bei youtube
videos anstatt von johannes huth ist bei
piloten oder von der anderen länder dann
haben wir überlegt dies wäre mit neuer
cool zu fliegen das könnte gut
ausschauen das kann ja gut das kann er
nicht so gut und dann hoffen wir diese
figuren aufgeschäumt den simulator sie
ist und dann bin ich an den figuren auf
der anderen bis die fertig gebastelt
[Musik]
diese
leistungsfähigkeit weiter der ist
wirklich herausragend stark von den
verkehr das versuche in szene zu setzen
das beginnt bereits beim den kopf es
gibt eine vielflieger 1000 eco von
doppelten aufschwung fliegen können
weiter kann das und diese wenigkeit
muss erhöht und diese fähigkeit dass man
mit 17 tonnen so internen kam mit neun g
und so schnell steigen kannst werden die
kralle steigflug es möglich das
kurzprogramm
wir haben kein autopilot ist groß wir
sind in sehr die verhöre unterwegs
während ein flug ist es so wie immer bei
jedem trainingsflug man konzentriert
sich auf seine zahlen am set up display
auf die werte weg sein programm herunter
und und danach ist quasi das bnd könne
dass mir die ganzen menschen sind
[Musik]
der kurs des euro weiter fiel das
christina
[Musik]